es wird ihnen nicht entgangen sein
deutschland streitet weiter über den
berliner mieten deckel später sieg der
ddr oder doch notwehr gegen mietwucher
tatsache ist zumindest in beliebten
großstädten wo also die arbeit meistens
ist können sich immer weniger
normalverdiener den luxus wohnen leisten
keine ahnung ob der mieten deckel da
wirklich die lösung ist aber es läuft
tatsächlich einiges aus dem ruder bei
uns einiges stichwort
wohnungsmodernisierung ihr noch ein paar
eine spar einrichtung für die
toilettenspülung
der ehemalige berufsschullehrer und die
pensionierte apothekenhelferin zahlen
momentan sieben euro pro quadratmeter
in zukunft sollen es fast 19 euro sein
ja aber dafür sparen sie auf dem klo
beim spülen wasser
das gleicht sich aus in berlin kann man
dank mieten decke demnächst nur noch
einen euro
modernisierungskosten pro quadratmeter
auf die miete drauf schlagen
und von wegen der markt regelt das alles
schon alleine quatsch der wert der miet
immobilien hat sich in den letzten zehn
jahren in vielen städten bei uns
verdoppelt die mieten sind um 50 prozent
gestiegen in berlin im schnitt sogar um
70 prozent der markt gerade in die
hauptstadt ist ein eldorado für
spekulanten für spekulanten aus aller
welt deshalb hat der rot rot grüne
senator wohl mal auf pause gedrückt und
die mieten für fünf jahre eingefroren
natürlich muss man zusätzlich ohne ende
bauen ist ja klar
andererseits wo findest du heute noch
handwerker die zeit haben müsste in dem
einsatz zur sozialistischen produktion
in meiner schulzeit mauern hecken mauern
und alles ja
es ist ja hier also also ja merkel kann
sogar ein mauer
wenn friedrich merz demnächst
verschwunden ist
ja berlin das ist tatsache baut viel zu
wenig wegen bürokratie baupreisen und
wegen berlin halten allgemeine
chronische unfähigkeit 30.000 wohnungen
wollte der senat in dieser
legislaturperiode hinkriegen das wurde
zuletzt schon auf für 25.000 runter
geredet was ist denn da los in der
hauptstadt die kriegen ja nichts
gebacken
eigentlich sei das baurecht einbau
verhinderungs recht sagen viele in der
branche
das ist grotesk des empire state
building würde wurde innerhalb von 15
monaten gebaut
ja ja aber nicht von berlinern abgesehen
davon abgesehen davon selbst wenn da
mehr gebaut würde
wer sich die miete im altbau nicht mehr
leisten kann wegen erhöhung dem helfen
auch keine neubauten denn die sind in
der regel wissen sie noch teurer und
fallen eben nicht unter den
kommunistischen mieten deckel und
irgendwas muss ja passieren es muss was
passieren zumal unsere bundesweit
gültige mietpreis bremse einen
entscheidenden nachteil hat sie bremst
nicht schlecht vorschlag vielleicht
könnte man spekulanten auch abschrecken
indem man ihn nicht mehr erlaubt sich
mit sogenannten share deals um die
grunderwerbsteuer zu drücken
der käufer des sony center in berlin hat
sich auf diese weise zum beispiel ganz
legal 66 millionen euro gespart
66 millionen die dem land berlin fehlen
66 millionen euro
dafür könnte man am berliner flughafen
schon wieder keine ahnung drei neue
feuerlöscher einbauen
aber wer weiß noch ist nicht entschieden
vielleicht wird er ihre mieten deckel ja
noch vor gericht gestoppt es kann
passieren dass sonst herrschen hier
nämlich irgendwann zustände wie im wien
freunde wo der markt seit jahrzehnten
von der stadt reguliert wird mit
katastrophalen auswirkungen hier im karl
marx hof ist gerade eine wohnung frei
geworden und wurde vor der neuvermietung
frisch renoviert diese 58 quadratmeter
gibt es beispielsweise für 337 euro
ich werde viele deutsche vermieter die
das gerade gesehen haben müssen jetzt
künstlich beatmet werden klar es ist ein
fakt unsere immobilienbranche muss sich
möglicherweise tankdeckel um ständig
begrüße dazu matthias matschke vom
eigentümerverband haus & grund matschke
gleich vor ort mal eine persönliche
frage wie wie geht es ihnen jetzt mit
dem neuen mieten decke was macht das so
man ihn
ich will nicht lügen
es tut schon weh ganz tief da drin
ich bin ja erfahren auch viel
solidarität ich möchte da auch noch mal
ganz ausdrücklich danke sagen dass fast
alle deutschen leitmedien diesen mieten
decke kritisiert haben als das
stalinistische verbrechen das er ist da
konnte man irgendeine zeitung
aufschlagen handelsblatt fatale folgen
für private vermieter bz so macht
rot-rot-grün unsere wirtschaft kaputt
und bild wahnsinns plan gegen berliner
mieten wahnsinn das hat so gutgetan
morgen titelt übrigens die faz damit
weihnachten nicht ausfällt kinder von wo
novia geschäftsführer müssen ihre nieren
verkaufen
das stimmt wo sie es sagen auch in den
fernsehberichten zum decke wurden fast
ausschließlich so niedliche alte kleinst
vermieter interviewt die sich jetzt
sorgen machen
obwohl für diese leute ausdrücklich eine
härtefallklausel vorgesehen ist und nie
vertreter der zwölf wohnungsunternehmen
den in berlin 250.000 wohnungen gehören
das ist ja genau der punkt armut durch
mieten decke kann jeden treffen
na ja also das was mal vielleicht vom
handwerksmeister der gleich zehn
wohnungen hat und dachte damit kann er
seine altersvorsorge machen das steht
erstmal in den sternen der kleine
handwerksmeister mit gerade mal zehn
wohnungen weil die entschuldigung wenn
die zehn wohnungen verkauft sind dass
irgendwas zwischen drei und fünf
millionen euro das reicht nicht fürs
alter ja ich weiß nicht wie sie ihr
alter sich vorstellen aber ich stelle
mir mein schöner vorher welt ich will ja
gar nicht leugnen dass die mieten
zuletzt ein bisschen ja explodiert sind
das trifft mittlerweile schon die
mittelschicht ich bin selber mieter in
berlin und weiß also wie die probleme
sind und wie die mieten gesteht ich
glaube nicht dass ihr problem hat nur
wohnungen zu kriegen ja aber auf der
friedrichstraße in berlin wäre es mir zu
teuer gewesen also nämlich aus
schönenberg eine längere anfahrt in kauf
unglaublich jetzt muss der bündner also
nicht der lindner sondern der fahrer vom
lindner jeden tag von schöneberg nach
mitte das sind 4 5 km 1
ich bin noch so klar es gibt
fehlentwicklungen andererseits müssen
wir doch stolz sein dass deutschland als
gastfreundliches land heimatlos um geld
von investoren aus aller welt ein
zuhause gibt
ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich was dieser
werden die nasa da macht das ist für
mich rassismus ausländer geld raus das
hat man schon mal sorry
wer ende 2011 in berlin gekauft hat ja
hat seine investitionen seitdem mehr als
verdoppelt ich kann da wirklich kaum
mitleid empfinden ja weil sie ein
herzloser schwein sind liebe zuschauer
klavier ab gerade vor weihnachten ist es
schön zu wissen dass man nicht allein
ist wie wunderbar dass das zdf seine
traditionelle gala ein herz für kinder
in diesem jahr spontan umbenennt in ein
herz für mieten deckel opfer
bitte spenden sie reichlich egal ob geld
oder wohnraum
jeder quadratmeter hilft danke matthias
matschke mal warum
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße